well let's talk about this uh let's look
this story i'm sure many people are
probably already familiar with this
because this actually came out yesterday
afternoon
but i thought it was uh important enough
to kick off the conversation and i'll
just say i mean
we were already having a pretty crazy
philosophical conversation before things
got started but let's talk about you
know black lives matter these riots
for those that haven't seen the news we
have this from k a r eleven
quote i wish it didn't have to happen
alternate jarrah reflects on derek
chovin trial
now the first and most important thing
is she didn't know she was an alternate
she was in the trial the same as
everyone else treating exactly the same
as any other juror
it was only once they announced
deliberations he said
juror 96 and you're you know so-and-so
you're you are our alternates you can go
and that's when she's like okay so her
her mentality
i believe is indicative of the the views
of many of the other jurors
however to be fair this is the juror who
lived in brooklyn center where the dante
right riots were happening
she literally had to drive through the
riots on the way to court
we have this uh so this is an interview
and we have this uh
let me let me just let me just read
regoose the the journalist says quote
did you want to be a juror
and the juror says i had mixed feelings
there was a question on the quest there
was a question on the questionnaire
about it
and i put i did not know the reason at
the time was i did not know what the
outcome was going to be
so i felt like either way you're going
to disappoint one group or the other
i did not want to go through rioting and
destruction again and i was concerned
about people coming to my house if they
were not happy with the verdict
do you think this lady reasonably feared
trump supporters or conservatives
rioting and showing up at her house i
think she feared insurrectionists
and i know that we're supposed to
believe that trump supporters are the
insurrectionists but
we did see an insurrection last year we
saw it go on for months
we saw it go on not just in one city or
two cities that went on around the
country
didn't just target government buildings
it targeted private businesses
and private citizens resulted in deaths
arson
terrorism what else do you call it
terrorism is when you target civilians
to achieve a political end
and look i get why she feared it i mean
there was a babylon b headline
right before the verdict came out it
said the jurors read their last will and
testimony
because of course and so should this
have led to a mistrial
right that was the big question yep
maxine waters calls for riots
joe biden later on i'm sorry i'm sorry
i've interrupted maxine waters incited
insurrection
yes i'm sorry incited an insurrection uh
joe biden same thing
he put his thumb on the scales for the
for the jury and
ultimately they go to convict him
because they wouldn't rule a mistrial
you remember the judge said
well hey this is bad you know i wish
waters didn't do that but anyway it's
okay they're probably not reading the
news so we're not going to have a
mistrial but i bet you got something on
appeal
so what do you say when he says i bet
you got something on appeal he's saying
i should declare a mistrial but i'm too
cowardly because i don't want them to
burn down my house
and so here's my my only point on it is
okay this juror comes out and says yeah
i was terrified of the mob
killing me and burning down my city um
why is the the judge on the appeal
gonna feel any differently than the
judge during the trial gonna feel any
differently than the jurors
everyone's afraid of this terrorist
left-wing mob because
they not only are making the threats
they're credible threats
because they already did it and they
already got away with it
it's terrorism and the funny thing is
they're bragging about it on twitter
yeah there's a meme right now so i
tweeted uh what did i
tweeted something like i said like holy
s you know
and a quote from the lady saying i don't
want to go through the riots and some
left is supposed to meme where it's you
know that the guy sweating and with the
two buttons yeah
and it said violence doesn't solve
anything the riots caused the show
inverted i'm like you're celebr
you're encouraging the right to get
violent yeah like i'm trying to tell
people not to get violent because
you don't want violence and here you
have the left gloating and bragging that
they engaged in acts of terrorism
yeah outside successfully what's scary
though is
i i guess for one i
don't really think it's a conservative
and liberal thing i think the issue is i
often describe it as politically
initiated and uninitiated
so why is it that you know i'm a fairly
moderate kind of you know left-leaning
libertarian type and we're laughing in
agreeing
it's because we both know that no true
facts
yeah there's probably some things we
disagree on in terms of what we think
may be real
but as individuals who are discerning of
the news and seeking out the truth
we both know certain facts yeah the
riots exist
they terrify people it's for a political
goal we might disagree on policy
but we agree on what's happening in this
country but most of these liberals and
these people who are voting for
democrats have no idea
they don't pay attention so in their
defense by the way
tim let's just take that story that
happened
what two days ago in columbus where the
cops shot the girl who was stabbing the
other girl
about to stab i'm sorry it was it was
just
all well and good that kind of you know
you're a kid you
there's no way to know if she was really
gonna stop you don't know there's a
little innocent shanking between friends
and so if you
were just a regular american right a
regular kind of liberal american you
don't watch your show you don't watch my
show
you're you're you know maybe you don't
watch podcasts maybe you
watch network news which is still the
way millions of americans get their news
and you watch nbc and you watch lester
holt's broadcast
the nightly news you would not have seen
the knife
they he they edited out the knife they
played the clip
the the girl is about to shank the other
girl they freeze the frame but keep the
audio going so the knife is out of the
frame
and all you hear is bang bang bang bang
the girl goes down
and then in the news report they say and
the the police officers say she was
holding a knife
a knife was later found on the ground no
way they show a picture of the knife on
the ground on the ground yeah
on the ground so it's not not their
fault that they're being lied to
so i think i talked about last week
there was a clip from mike.com all right
i'm at a trump rally in janesville
wisconsin this is back in like 2015 or
2016.
this young woman was arguing with it
with an older man and everyone's raucous
and in a crowd
and she's yelling he touched my breast
he touched my breast and the old guy had
his hands up saying i did not touch you
i didn't touch you
she punches him in the face and then
someone else pepper sprays her
mike.com added a flare
as if they were doing an edit because it
was the weirdest thing ever
she goes he touched my breast he touched
my breast and then the screen flashes
white
to cover up the punch and then it shows
her getting pepper sprayed
and the story they run is woman sexual
you know teenager is sexually assaulted
and then pepper sprayed by trump
supporters
and i'm like yeah man
that's the news we get and the problem
is you know my pal
andrew clavin makes this point a lot
when we
read the news or we watch a news story
about something that we know about
we we can look at it and say hmm yeah
that doesn't sound right to me
uh no i actually know that's not true
now i actually have my own lion eyes
here you know and i knew that that was
not true
but then when we get to another story
where we don't i don't know iran or
something right so i'm not an expert on
we just take their word for it the thing
we know about we know they're lying to
us but then the rest
who knows that's the gel man amnesia
effect yes have you heard the that's
so there was a guy who said he was going
to name it after two smart people so it
sounds official
so i don't know i don't know i remember
who actually coined the phrase but
man it's it it rings true iran is a
really great example when i see cnn say
something like you know
hezbollah has done this i just go like i
guess yeah maybe
and then i watch them talk about the
riots of like peaceful protesters burned
down the city and i'm like it must have
been peaceful
yeah am i yes is hezbollah good i don't
know i don't know i don't i don't think
that's the case but who knows what
they're lying about you know right yeah
and so
when especially when it comes to foreign
policy yeah we get into wars because of
it because the american people are just
i guess i just trust it and so that
that's kind of why
i i think the easiest example of this is
true
the real political divide or one i
shouldn't say the real but this one of
the strongest
is do you actually pay attention to the
world worldly affairs
because you and i will disagree on
politics but we agree on what's
happening
with the world which allows us to you
know applying a standard american moral
framework
come to similar conclusions on what
should or shouldn't be yeah and and
there's also
if you really want to get woke to the
political scene one has to recognize
there is a difference
between how the government is supposed
to work and how the government works on
paper
and how the government actually works
and the kind of real
ruling establishment and actually the
right wing is finally waking up to this
a little bit
when you know for 20 years the right
wing talked about how
there's the you know the public and the
private and the government and business
and you know public government bad
private business good
and yeah maybe this woke multinational
corporation is undermining our entire
country and culture but
but they're good they're good company
give money to company give tax cut to
company and government
even though the government is an
expression of our own political wills
through
through our elected representatives we
hope when it's working bad right
but now what is google is
google's a private company no we were by
squishy republicans we were told
google's a private company for a long
time
that doesn't seem that private to me
when when three billionaire oligarchs
control the flow of information in a
republic where speech
is politics right it's the same thing
the way we govern ourselves is we
persuade one another of things
if three companies are controlling that
that practically speaking is the
government
you know i i go back and forth on this
sometimes depending on the news
depending on you know how it's
it's hard to gauge whether we are
winning or losing and by we i mean the
people who believe in individual rights
free expression
and uh i guess i think we're classified
classically
so you know there was a funny comment
earlier someone in the chat said
they saw michael in the title and they
were hoping for malice but they got
nulls instead
real nice they're like okay it's real
nice guys
but you know michael mouse of the
opinion that we're winning yeah that uh
and there's there's good reasons to
think so like youtube just relaxed its
rules
on uh community guidelines and
monetization some of them
give people pause like you're now
allowed to show police brutality videos
and monetize them which is
you know they think that's that's
actually the other direction it it
popularizes the myth
of police going on hunting microwaves
and things like that right but they also
have now opened it up to you know more
adult themed content to put it mildly
like news coverage
very serious you know issues swearing
even and so maybe that's a move in the
right direction
i wonder though if some of the
relaxation is just because
the election passed this is why the
election's over thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time